hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday
january 24th what's going on how are ya
how's it going
how are you hot how's your sporting
heart after this weekend of playoff
football
jesus christ i'll tell you two weeks ago
it was a [ __ ] snoozefest
nothing but [ __ ] blowouts
this past uh last week the weekend
before this past weekend i know how to
say it not this weekend the weekend
before
and this week i mean right now i got
it's the second quarter
and i got the [ __ ] uh
the bills and the chiefs game on
right now so uh
if you were sleeping
under a rock
you know
if you were quarantining to the to the
point you don't even [ __ ]
watch television because you're afraid
someone on tv is going to breathe on you
this is what happened
your los angeles rams
beat
my second team the tom brady buccaneers
that was a tough one to watch
that was a tough one to watch that
reminded me
of when the giants
would beat the patriots and it was like
tom brady did his job
and then the defense would just [ __ ]
let us down
well maybe not the first one i really
think it was the giants front four on
that one but like tom in the end of the
game drove down got us the touchdown
okay all you got to do is stop them and
then they just
let them go down the field i don't
[ __ ] understand
how that goddamn safety waits till
cooper cup is parallel with him
and he's not running full speed at that
point like what are you doing the
safety's not running full speed he like
it's like one go out there one [ __ ]
thing don't let him get behind you
don't let him i can't believe they
weren't in the stupid prevent i actually
appreciate the fact that they were
actually playing defense
but uh i don't know that i mean
get [ __ ] burned underneath
guess that he's going deep let him
[ __ ] break off the route and then you
curl around you you tackle him after he
[ __ ] catches the ball i don't know
it's easy for me to say you can't even
[ __ ] run a
i mean i think i'd ran a 40-yard dash
between seven and eight seconds when i
was 18 in the prime of my life
i'm slow as [ __ ] sorry i have a cold no
i don't have covet i keep get keep
testing
i keep [ __ ] testing it keeps coming
back negative
i did one of those [ __ ] the psats i
did a rapid or whatever the [ __ ] you
call them
pcrs
i keep doing that so i don't know i
don't know what's going on here i have
no idea um
i think i was just run down from
traveling
and then i smoked a stick
and then but you know
then the second you get sick everybody's
like oh my god what is that
are you all right and it's like all
right let me take a test okay i came
negative okay
but it could not show up until tomorrow
all right
okay
so what is that why did i get tested
just to see if i had it
okay it's saying i don't have it all
right but that doesn't mean you don't
don't have it it just means it's not
showing up it's like all right i'll
keep [ __ ] i love it man i've been
[ __ ] sitting here
my robo [ __ ]
out by the garage just [ __ ] watching
football staying away from everybody
keeps going all right you gotta you
gotta keep testing for another [ __ ] i
was like all right okay i'll keep doing
that i'll keep [ __ ]
you know what are you gonna do my drums
are out here i've been having a great
time
um but speaking of which yeah so tom
brady goes down i mean the [ __ ] rams
did everything they could to give them
that game and tom brady as he always
[ __ ] does
you know
goes down and gets to score to put you
ahead and tie it up or whatever
and then the rams i mean the bucks had
one [ __ ] jump
don't let what happened happen
[ __ ] unreal
you know
i'll tell you the craziest one though
the craziest one was the [ __ ]
was the 49ers beating the packers unless
something crazy happens in this bill's
jets game
i mean i
was like
i was on the phone with somebody
when they blocked that punt
and it just stayed up in the air forever
and i was just screaming oh my god
that was
shout out to all the packers fans that
died a thousand deaths
as that thing stayed up in the air for
like a minute and there was nothing but
49er jerseys around it
i was thinking is he gonna try to pick
it up and kick it out of the back of the
end zone he scooped it right up
and scored a [ __ ] touchdown it was
unfucking
believable
i couldn't believe it and when the
[ __ ]
when uh domica sue caused that fumble
one another one oh my god just screaming
oh my god it was the most exciting
weekend of football it's [ __ ] amazing
but um
i don't know i got to be honest i am not
buying the 49ers i'm just not
i think uh
i don't know this feels like a weird
year in the nfl you know it's a
transitional thing where like
roethlisberg is retiring that might have
been tom brady's last game
um
i feel like uh
you know mahomes is the guy
russell wilson
and then there's like two like open
slots there's usually three or four
you know on the mount rushmore of any
period
you know we used to be brady payton i'd
say drew brees
roethlisberger i know aaron rodgers was
in there obviously
um
wait i didn't include aaron rodgers i'm
acting like he's retiring so right now
it's mahomes aaron rodgers and russell
wilson i don't know it just feels like
it feels like a weird year maybe because
there's so many like new teams in there
and there's so many guys like playing
right now that don't have rings
so it just feels like it just feels odd
but it's kind of [ __ ] cool like
seeing the bills
and the uh and the chiefs playing each
other in the playoffs i don't think i've
ever [ __ ] seen that
i don't know that that's happened since
i've been watching football let me let
me look that up
because the the bills had a couple of
okay years in the early
80s as did the chiefs but they never
amounted to
playoffs maybe a wild card let's see
here
last time
the bills
played the chiefs
in the playoffs
you kidding me
playoffs that's my favorite part of it
okay
well here's the last last time
the bills and chiefs played the bills
lost 38-24
[Music]
bills versus chief's playoff history
uh
there is a trend watching
this is just like cooking videos just
give me the [ __ ] answer
there is a trend there that bears
watching in the next few weeks shut the
[ __ ] up all right the chiefs won the
1966 afl championship game in buffalo
which enabled them to play in the very
first super bowl
where they lost to the dynastic green
bay packers of vince lombardi dynastic i
didn't know that was a word
uh there you go they haven't played
since 66
in the playoffs playoffs
playoffs you kidding me
um
you know i love you kidding me
that's that's dangerfield
my mother-in-law oh you kidding
oh you kid i love that you kidding um
anyway
um let's see here uh
what was i talking about i was talking
about the bill chiefs anyways the 49ers
see i'm just not feeling like they are
100 this solid unit
and of the teams that are left right now
when i'm watching this once again the
teams left are the uh rams the bengals
the 49ers and the winner of the uh
chiefs versus the bills i feel like the
rams have the best defense
now when i was a kid right up until my
mid-40s defense won championships
but they have made so many [ __ ] rule
changes
you know i mean look at field goals i am
still i'm living in the past with that
i'm still doing the old 23 skidoo when
you guys moved on to the jitterbug there
like this whole [ __ ] thing like
like it's like field goals got me tooed
i literally just watched the bills drove
right down the field their first
possession
some real [ __ ] calls i gotta be honest
with you the [ __ ] qb option what are
we playing [ __ ] high school football
here
you know ran that twice
um so then it becomes fourth and goal
i'm like all right you kick it hey take
the points
get some [ __ ] points on the board
they didn't they went for it on fourth
down and i'm like this is [ __ ]
ridiculous and they got it
now
there's a lot of sports fans who aren't
good at math so they go well there you
go that's why you go for it but it's
like
but if you don't get it
you know
you're leaving that three points out
there and that i still feel that that
[ __ ] adds up over the game over the
game you keep going for it you know
and you make it one out of three times
so you get yourself seven points but you
could have had nine
you know i don't understa i don't i
don't get it
although i did pick an example where the
math worked out in my favor
it starts adding up but
i don't know
the coach of the bills
said that he thinks that it's that you
should go for it and uh he last i
checked he coaches an nfl team and i
don't despite what twitter is saying
that is not me
uh this game's really settled down
um i got a weird feeling i think the
rams are going to win the super bowl
i'll say this if it's if the bills beat
the [ __ ] chiefs
i like the rams to win it all
i just think that front four is is a
[ __ ] problem and i don't care how
good your quarterback is
including josh allen that he can run and
do all of that [ __ ] uh those guys are
like
they're reminding me of those giant
teams
they used to frustrate the pats
um
and cause brady to be uncomfortable and
move out of the pocket and all of that
[ __ ] we shall see
we
shall see i still
love a few i mean let's see i'm sitting
here talking about field goals the field
goals [ __ ]
won every goddamn game this weekend what
am i talking about people seem to ignore
all of that
you know i guess that that's when you
kick a field goal right in the end
they're gonna just gonna come out like
like [ __ ] mariana rivera just the end
of the game to close it out like who's
the [ __ ] bengals field goal kicker
guy was talking crazy [ __ ]
before he comes out on the field he goes
congratulations we're all going to the
afc championship game and he goes out
there and kicks a 52 yarder
that's what i'm [ __ ] talking about
that's the [ __ ]
that's way you know when you fantasize
when you're having your fantasies in
your car and you're whispering [ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] you say
yeah i'll see you next week at the amc
championship
you know
and your wife goes what did you say yeah
not nothing i was just uh i was
working on some material
and she looks at you and you look back
at her you try to smile and she knows
that there's something [ __ ] wrong
with you
she starts thinking like i really bred
with this person like my kids are half
that
some guy who has fantasies about kicking
a game-winning field goal at 53
while driving down the street with
everybody in the car on their way to get
tacos
that's what i married
and that's when you just got to square
up and look right at her and be like
yeah
that is what you married and you got no
one to blame but yourself
[Laughter]
that's when you know you're an [ __ ]
you can't you don't have an argument
left
is when you say to your wife hey you
knew who i was when you married me
that's one of my favorite
[ __ ] um
i guess do-overs a mulligan how i get
out of [ __ ]
hey you knew who i was when you married
me
sweetheart you knew i was a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
in difficult like what three months into
the relationship and they usually take
the bait yeah easily three months all
right well what are you still doing here
do you ever think on some level maybe
you wanted a little more of a difficult
life
what is gaha field i thought it was
arrowhead stadium
g-e-h-h g-e-h-a
advance social justice
thank you nfl
what do they have on the sidelines be
nice to people wow they're really going
i'll tell you the nfl they got some hot
takes don't they
advanced social justice yes you don't
[ __ ] pay anybody they got a
concussion would you give them
collectively 40 bucks each
you took them to subway
[Music]
um patrick mahomes completes
i'll tell you the [ __ ] uh
8 32 to go
in the second quarter
um i got to be honest with the super
bowl that i wanted to see i wanted to
see the the buffalo bills against the
tom brady buccaneers that's the one that
i wanted to see i wanted to see
the storybook ending for the buffalo
bills where they beat bill belichick and
then they beat tom brady i wanted that
or
i wanted to see
tom brady
one more time
impose his will
on that city
like they should have a statue of tom
brady in downtown buffalo they just
should
at least give him the key to the city
i mean did anybody
did any
professional quarterback in the history
of the nfl
send more buffalo locals over the
niagara falls in a [ __ ] whiskey
barrel than tom brady
um
oh god he just sidearmed the bar the
ball now we're gonna have to [ __ ]
listen to that for the rest of the game
did you just see what he did i can't
[ __ ] but that is unbelievable it's
like did you not see kent to culvey when
you were growing up
i gotta admit i don't see a lot of
people do that
that is a nice ball
all right i'll give it up for him that
was nice i thought right now one of the
key to the game
one of the key games right now is tyreek
hilt
if they could shut if they can shut down
tyreek
hill and make them beat them with their
oh jesus lsu
there you go
edward's hella hilal heller hello
whatever his name is
see what they're going to create a hole
right there and there's just nobody home
49 came all the way up in he needed to
stay home he did and all of a sudden
they're all the way down to the 19 and a
half yard line hyde with a nice oh jesus
the big whiff what the [ __ ] is that when
did people stop using their [ __ ] arms
when they tackle i'm gonna dive into you
this isn't a stunt
i'll tell you what i don't understand
as you explained to me
why the green bay packers had some kid
six foot four 228
on the line trying to block a guy six
foot four 270. the poor kid was giving
away 42 [ __ ] pounds
you have davey versus goliath
on your [ __ ]
special maybe that's why you have a
problem on special teams did somebody
get hurt
you needed some 300 pound
[ __ ] fatty you look like he just got
off a harley
big [ __ ] square head head you know
with those cheeks that get pushed in
when he [ __ ] puts a helmet on to the
point you can't even tell his
nationality
it just stuffed in there oh look at
edward's hillary look at the guy just
ducking under and over
tell you right now
this this game is flying by
all right
i'm feeling the momentum shifting right
now these buffalo bills better do
something
because if they go down here and they
score a [ __ ] touchdown
uh and go up 14 to seven
this is a team they have a lot of
veterans with a lot of playoff
experience you gotta be thinking that
they're gonna start to settle in do the
buffalo bills get a little more tighter
here
i swear to god i could do that job if i
didn't curse so much
it's no different than doing fox news or
cnn
you just you always introduce some
fearful thought
you know does joe biden
is joe biden handling russia
and and
and [ __ ] that other place uh the
proper way
it's funny i know the name was it kiev i
know the name of the capitol for some
reason i'm black blanket on the [ __ ]
uh
the country
i don't know i don't pay attention to
the [ __ ] news anymore
and uh i just [ __ ] i just like i muted
and anybody who's talking [ __ ] virus
[ __ ] i muted or unfollowed
and i just i just can't listen to it
anymore
anybody who says biden's america or
trumpsters this or that just done it's
[ __ ] great
you know
now all i have is workout videos life
coaches
and uh
rappers yelling about [ __ ]
oh man speaking of that i saw this
[ __ ] guy holy [ __ ]
i saw this guy going off i didn't you
know one person he was talking about
any black listeners out here you got to
you got to help me up you got to help a
white guy out here you don't have to
considering our history but it would be
nice if you could be the bigger person
here
um
this [ __ ] guy
i remember his first name
his first name was charleston
and he was [ __ ] going off
on all these guys going like the
[ __ ] out here giving me [ __ ]
he [ __ ] a child
that's how he opened i was like oh my
god
[ __ ] 10 minutes just going off on
people hang on a second i'm going to
find this for you
put in the right
thing here
all right where are we going
um
kansas city's offensive coordinator is
adorable he looks like he should be in
some christmas city
like welcoming you
he did he looked like a [ __ ] snowman
oh jesus oh jesus
you know mahomes has a real dainty way
of running we stop look at the guy
[ __ ] point yeah yeah something
happened down there see they always say
brady does that he [ __ ] does it too
he was falling down throw the flag over
there
all right sorry
anyways let me see something here
okay
charleston
white i think that's his name i looked
this guy up that's the guy oh my god
this [ __ ] dude went off
just came up on my [ __ ] instagram
he just
he was not
holding back
um
anyway
he said a lot of crazy [ __ ] you know
i think yeah wait wait i i was kind of
falling asleep oh hell hey
almost almost
i was starting to fall asleep yeah he
gets a little sideways at one point you
know
possibly anti-semitic i didn't really
understand how he was saying it but it
is i do appreciate somebody just saying
exactly what they're thinking and not
giving a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
um
as opposed to uh
public speaking speak
you know
it's kind of a weird thing if you don't
agree with somebody if they're just
really saying how they feel
you're like wow
was the last time i heard that
as opposed to people going like well you
know it was a difficult situation and uh
you know we put our heads together we
tried to uh navigate um the rough waters
and uh not saying that we got it right
not saying we got it wrong and we still
have a journey ahead of us
and um but we have an open door policy
and we're going to listen and we're
going to get this right
now that right there you could literally
drop me into a presidential debate and
not even tell me what the question was
and i could have i could just say that
then i would move on to the next round
mr president uh what do you feel about
the current situation
over in that country whose capital is
kiev
this is disrespectful to them i need to
[ __ ] know the name of the country why
can't i remember it
i root for those guys
the ukraine i root for the ukraine
they're on my fantasy team of countries
you know certain countries you root for
other countries you don't root for right
you know you root for ireland
you don't root for england right because
england's the [ __ ]
you root for scotland
even though they're part of great
britain
you know even though they should be
their own country you root for them
you don't root for england because
they're the [ __ ]
right
you root for norway
you root for finland you don't root for
sweden because they're the [ __ ]
i might be wrong
i might be wrong in this
all right
you root for poland
you root for hungry
you stay away from germany and
austria because i don't know they're
they you don't know what the [ __ ]
they're gonna do
right
they're scary
um
let me see who else
you root for australia
right
because they're like discarded white
people all the way down at the bottom of
the world
really just sort of cut off from
everyone
just down there with all those poisonous
snakes and [ __ ] i mean how do you not
root for them
plus they got a bunch of great sports
australian rules football ah patrick
mahomes just underhanded the ball like
he was throwing it to a toddler
i mean that is unbelievable
um
that's literally a forward lateral i
don't know why they always [ __ ] lose
their [ __ ] when they do that say they
got a lot of looks down there a lot of
razzle downs
you don't know where it's coming from
he lateraled the ball forward like
that's how i taught my daughter how to
play catch
um
well g bill aren't you just the king of
the gridiron having not played past the
third grade patrick mahomes rolling out
stopping throwing it oh touchdown
patrick mahomes
come on buffalo
patrick mahomes feeling it feeling it
patrick mahomes undeniable greatness as
much as i tease him or whatever you know
what you know i think the guy's great
i'm just making fun of you josh sounds
what happened they just scored a
touchdown
i'm sorry i'm from wyoming you know
i'm just a simple country boy we just
sit here put our hat on you know i'm not
even cold i'm just doing it
because the team told me to and i'm just
here to do whatever the team tells me to
do
patrick mahomes i mean
falling to his left throws to his right
touchdown i mean you know
i could sit here and be an old bald
freckle [ __ ] by the way i'm loving their
mascot doing the running man that's
[ __ ] that dude is amazing
um a bit of a duck but it got in there
all right yeah
state farm
um okay
so there you go 14 to seven people i
don't know why i'm announcing this like
you you don't already know what's
happening
look at everybody out in the desert
watching the commercial here i was just
out there wherever that is i was in an
area like that
where people have side-by-sides and
houseboats and [ __ ] like that that part
of america
the part of america that that hollywood
makes fun of holly weird
makes fun of you know all those people
in the middle of nowhere that always
call it holly weird you got a lot of
[ __ ] balls
how about i thank you every once in a
while for creating all of your content
huh
even those hunting fishing shows
well they got people on there that talk
like the way that you do those are just
actors
okay most of them
went to school at berkeley
in san francisco and they perfected your
accent
you know you think you're looking at a
good old boy you're not
it's a california liberal the second
he's done killing that yak
he puts on a pair of rainbow flip-flops
and goes and uses a gender-neutral
bathroom
and that's a true story
dude how great is brad garrett in these
[ __ ] jimmy john's commercials
he is so goddamn [ __ ] funny
that guy is so [ __ ] funny he is so
ridiculous
that that guy is not
all of these [ __ ] great movies you
know they have all these awesome
characters somebody's got to give that
guy a [ __ ] role in something
brad garrett in jimmy john commercials
is better than most movie stars in
[ __ ] movies
[Laughter]
he should be in one of those lock stock
and four smoking barrels things
something like that one of those cool
movies
um
all right let's get to the advertising
here for this week
by the way
um oh i've actually been playing uh
been playing a lot of drums here
and uh
i've been listening to a lot of old jazz
yes
is what's his face used to say on snl
listening to the yaz
um
and i always just like bebop
i always liked that the best that bertha
cool stuff and hard bop i just didn't
get into it i like bebop and then i like
you know bebop came after i guess big
band swing
and it was like
i was just reading like what makes
because i was talking to somebody and he
was
kind of debating when bebop was uh
when it came out and he was trying to
say it came after
the birth of cool and i was like i think
it came before
so i was looking it up or whatever so
that came out in the 40s and they were
saying that it was up tempo it was he
couldn't dance to it
and it sort of catered to like
people soloing and that type of stuff
and then after that
you know what people did you know didn't
sell well because people couldn't dance
to it then like birth to cool and hard
bought they slowed it down and they had
more melodies that you could hum
and then in the 60s i feel like jazz
said yeah well we don't give a [ __ ] if
you can't dance to this [ __ ] because
we're bored and now we're gonna we're
going for it so i love
the 40s bebop and this josh allen
putting it right away you're the only
place he could catch it
first down come on josh
i like both of these teams i'm not
rooting against kansas city either
i just want to see a good [ __ ] game
here i want to see an old school
[ __ ] shootout
um
yeah so i like to beep up and then i
like
the [ __ ] [ __ ] 1960s like
it's funny because you listen to those
miles once when john coltrane is in uh
in his quintent that quintet that first
one
um
i know like he totally would shed it
after that and really came up with his
sound and everything but like
i just like the stuff that he did with
alvin jones and all of those guys when
he just had the quartet when it was just
him and uh
was it elvin jones the other two guys i
[ __ ] love that [ __ ]
i don't know what the hell's going on
but i've been trying to play drums
to some of that stuff
and uh there's some really good albums
out there obviously that i didn't know
about this one that of charlie parker
and dizzy gillespie at massey hall in
toronto which i actually played one time
um
bill can we keep this about jazz and not
your stupid [ __ ] joke career okay fair
enough
i was saying it more as a fan that i was
excited don't try to defend yourself
bill we know what you're doing you're
trying to insert yourself
into that look at this he just keeps
throwing to the same part of the [ __ ]
field
what's going on here
i'm just a country boy
and i'm gonna [ __ ] oh stop hate yeah
good idea josh
good idea
what does patrick mahomes have increase
hate
um
stop hate
it's just got to be the [ __ ] the
stupidest lamest
what is that doing stop hate oh okay
all right i'll get on
that you know
or is it for people that hate other
people it's just like you know
i got to be honest i was going to keep
hating
then i was watching the bills versus the
chiefs and i saw it it said stop hate
and i figured if josh allen could put
that helmet on and not have a problem
with it
then maybe i i maybe i should stop
hating people
when did you stop being in the clan uh
second quarter of bills versus the
chiefs
interesting
um
all right
let's do some of the advertising here uh
did i copy and paste it did i copy and
paste it did i copy and paste it
is this it
okay
grove
g r
o
um
look at that [ __ ] josh allen running
like a young ben roethlisberger
ben roethlisberger meets steve young
he's got some wheels
big [ __ ] john wayne looking dude all
right grove
have some resolutions
to be more sustainable
that's a sentence
have some resolutions to be more
sustainable question mark make it easy
and start with eliminating single-use
plastics oh i like this grove
collaborative is here with reusable
swaps
to make a lasting impact at home for
your family and the planet a new year
means a fresh stat
and a change to
a chance to change the way you care for
the planet now is the perfect time to
make your home healthier happier and
more sustainable discover everything you
need for a sustainable home at grove
collaborative oh man
i have an idea on how to i'll tell you
after this on an ad
on how to save the planet by using
plastic
a new year means new commitments to
those we care about family and planet
included yeah the number one important
thing is is uh not [ __ ] up this world
so we can live in it
uh if you've if you've been wait wanting
to make more sustainable choices for
your home for your home care beauty and
more start today with grove
collaborative ready to make 2022 the
best year yet for your family and the
planet start a sustainable revolution at
home with grove collaborative and shop
over 150 brands that make a real
impact go to grove.com
g-r-o-v-e
dot com touchdown bells baby
we got ourselves a shootout number third
oh wow we just sort of pushed the guy
down you can do that you're an offensive
player
is that what happened or do you get trip
over the other guy no they're not going
to show us they don't care they don't
care about cornerbacks
um
cornerbacks are the redheads of the nfl
nobody gives a [ __ ] uh go to grove.com
burt today to get a free gift set worth
up to 50 dollars and you're with your
first order plus shipping is free and uh
and fast get started right now
grove.com g-r-o-v-e dot com
b-u-r-r
grove.com how about the buffalo bills
answering
aaron rodgers throwing axes shaking off
that playoff loss all right headspace
everybody
headspace this is a friendly reminder
that anything that cost you your mental
health is too expensive
this time it's time this year it's time
to invest invest in yourself and finally
relieve your ongoing stress anxiety and
sleeplessness learn how to easily
improve your mental health and
well-being with headspace
we all say fine when we don't mean it
fine isn't really an emotion is it no
but it's a way to get through a moment
you know if you don't feel like opening
up
how you feeling fine
no really what's going on with you do
you really want me to dump that on you
or do you want to enjoy your
lunch i think i'm a candidate for head
space here people uh how many times have
you told yourself you're fine when all
you've really felt is anger or sadness
or nerves um
pretty much my entire conscious life
headspace headspace is scientifically
proven to help you manage your feelings
and your mental health in fact a recent
study proved in just two weeks head
headspace can reduce your stress by 14
whether you want to relieve stress and
anxiety sleep better or improve your
focus headspace is your everyday dose of
mindfulness for real life however
however you're feeling try headspace at
headspace.com
and get one month for free
of their entire mindfulness library
this is the best headspace offer
available so go to headspace.com
today headspace.com slash bur
i got to do that i got to do that for
myself and the people i love
all right so here's my idea on how to
use plastic and help the environment
um
i'm sort of stealing from grove
g-r-o-v-e
um
where basically
you know rather than having one-time use
of plastic bags
you have two uses
you use it right
you use it twice
you can't just use a plastic bag once
the new rule is you have to use it twice
so that immediately cuts down the amount
that we're going to use by 50 [ __ ]
percent and here's how we send it
through the roof
all right
if the plastic bag that you just used
and you're now done using and you want
to use it again if it's big enough to
put it over your head and suffocate
yourself to death
you do that
right
so you'll never use plastic again
dropping the numbers if it's too big to
get it over your face you then kill the
nearest person you see
with the small bag just sort of that you
can overpower
there you go just like that
you know i think that we uh we put a big
dent in it
no i'm only kidding this is just a joke
nobody kill somebody with a sandwich bag
okay
um all right i think it's time
now's the time to say goodbye to all our
badaboos
uh we're going to do some of the reads
here for the week
i'll tell you that he tyreek hill has
got to be one of the most elusive look
at what's his face [ __ ] disco dancing
there sean just sitting there keep the
clock rolling here
tyrique he doesn't run as much as he
dances across the field um all right
if i was a dictator
oh i got some new ones for you guys oh i
got some new ones
i got some [ __ ] new ones for you i
have some [ __ ] ones
for you
all right if you do something douchey
and somebody calls you out on it and you
know that you did something douchey but
you still have the balls to act like you
didn't [ __ ] know that you did it
yeah that's that's the death penalty
kelsey first down he's got to start
dancing come on kelsey this is what you
do you just caught a pass for four yards
it's time to [ __ ] start dancing
let's get a shoe contract out of it is
it me or the kansas city chiefs
helmets a little different red look at
josh allen just sitting there
picking [ __ ] out of his teeth he doesn't
give a [ __ ] this guy is so [ __ ] calm
and collective
i'll tell you he's eating buffalo wings
on the way to the game
um if i was a dictator this is the new
segment here people you get to run the
world you're fantasy running of the
world
all right if i was a dictator dear billy
boyle dinner
i love that one dear billy boyle dinner
if i was a dictator i would immediately
dismantle the mormon church whoa
wow
going in
all mormons will repl
will be placed in labor camps on
american indian reservations
all american indians will inherit the
money i steal from the mormons as i will
not accept it
look at you being the martyr here look
at you you're like the kevin costner for
this is like dancing was with wolves
except dancing with the dictator
dancing with dictators
take that to [ __ ] hollywood and sell
it uh it will also make me not look like
a sociopath
there you go a little self-deprecation i
like that the sole reason for the mormon
discrimination is because i want their
nuclear fallout vault located in little
cottonwood utah to get the vault i must
enslave an entire religion just as my
forefathers did
not sure exactly what i would do with
the vault once i get it as i do not know
the layout please use your imagination
cheers and go [ __ ] yourself i didn't
know they had a [ __ ] nuclear fallout
that's now there's a there's a religion
thinking about their people
wait a second
you know what i'm taking the bait i'm
gonna google i'm gonna google some
pictures let's see the fake photos that
come up
um
where's the goddamn web the inner web
here all right
mormons
fallout
shelter
was it cottonwood
cottonwood utah
i mean you can't tell me they don't have
an adorable place to get ice cream in
cottonwood utah
welcome to cottonwood
you like some ice cream that we just
made outside yes i would
mormons fallout shelter
the rosetta pro let's see images
images
the mormons vaults
oh wow
i mean those are pretty amazing
granite mountain vault they have
pictures of them
looks like a morgue to me
bomb shelter business is booming
i don't understand why anybody would
have a bomb shelter
what is the who wants to survive that
yeah no
by all means if you're gonna drop bombs
pick my house first thank you
i had a good time
i'm gonna [ __ ] sit there
eating rash and bread and all of that
[ __ ] i don't want to do that
um
war rash and horse [ __ ] eating [ __ ]
spam
listen to somebody muttering like
winston churchill we shall never
um
all right here's some here's some ideas
people have uh redrock's title
suggestion
hey bill just the thought
of a title for your red rock special
a ginger on the rocks
take it if you like it thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself uh dean delray right out
of the gate said billy red rocks is what
i should call it
which i loved and my wife was like don't
call it that
[Laughter]
um
wait did he just miss that field goal
oh christ i'm trying to be here for
field goal kickers and look what this
guy does
wide i don't know wide right
a lot of empty seats there in arrowhead
those big fat bastards just well that
barbecue coming out of their ass by the
second quarter
um
what the [ __ ] the bill's coach's name
sean what that guy runs as bad as i do i
can tell why you guys think he's me
bill's coach
it's sean mc something or other sean
john
mcdermott all right i got it now
all right art piece inspired by bill
burr hey bill you beautiful redheaded
[ __ ] oh i love a compliment
uh writing you for my best friend who is
a super fan of yours he listens to your
podcast all the time and
has found your humor to help him through
some difficult times
he created an art piece inspired by you
and called it monday morning
and he'd be tickled [ __ ] silly if you
had a look at the video he made for it
the link is below
uh thanks for watching and sharing your
sick humor with the world it's desperate
it's needed desperately now i'm gonna go
[ __ ] myself or you go [ __ ] yourself lol
all right well let me watch the video i
was wondering what that was let me see
if i can find it here
okay that's the mormon bomb shelter sean
mcdermott
charleston white
charleston charleston butt up
boo d d okay here we go
um
he's out there [ __ ] kids
all right
where is it mm content
okay i'm gonna watch this right now so
this guy will be tickled pink it's like
three minutes long buddy
all right there's no way you lose when
you go after a dream
nothing
is not going in oh jesus christ i'm
gonna have to watch that later
god i almost got my period listening to
that um
i'm gonna listen to it don't worry all
right canadian dictator
hey oh a canadian dictator now that's
that's an oxymoron
unless you've been to canada you realize
how evil those [ __ ] people are up
there you know you are you know who i'm
talking about
canadian dictator hey billy freckles you
wanted to hear a canadian dictator's
point of view
so i got one for you first thing i do is
increase the military budget many times
over no more flying your used [ __ ] from
the vietnam and gulf wars we need our
own fancy killing machines and lots of
them plus without the military backing
me i won't last now here's somebody did
some research i like this guy
or lady
um then it's time to shoot some corrupt
politicians that have been taking bribes
from big corporations and ignoring the
needs of the people i'd shoot them right
in the house of commons live on tv so
people know that stealing from the what
what's stealing from the country gets
you jesus
next on the list is taking possessions
of all the natural resources and minds
all the natural resources and mines and
[ __ ] would be run by the country and the
profits would be returned to the country
to make it a better place for the
average joe
next it's time to ban corporate and
foreign ownership of this well then you
better kill a lot more [ __ ] people
than just the corrupt politicians you
got to kill those [ __ ] uh guys
running your uh oil companies
uh
that'd be a fun
you know if you were hit man
just like great locations just a degree
of difficulty going into those gated
communities
and then the satisfaction
of killing some fat corporate guy who's
in like a white bathrobe
sitting there with his [ __ ] in a hot
tub i mean it's fun it's like you're in
scarface
um
anyways next is to ban corporate and
foreign ownership of single family and
detached homes and condos i like that
houses should be for living and not to
profit from
uh
[ __ ] maybe the government can use the
extra natural resource money to make
sure everyone who wants a house can get
one built for free it's not like canada
doesn't have enough [ __ ] room
um i would reward any citizen who can
find efficiency improvement improvements
in any aspect of government no more
waste the money so we can have the same
budget next year kind of [ __ ]
then i dismantle the stock market
because [ __ ] [ __ ] it why not
you know your heart's in the right place
um hence i don't think you'd make it
till three in the afternoon
um all fines will be replaced by
community service because if the
punishment for breaking the law is a
fine then it's only a law for the poor
the temporary foreign worker program
that's a good point
if it's a fine it's only a law for the
poor
yeah because what's the deterrent if
you're a rich guy the temporary foreign
worker program would be abolished the
way employers treat those foreign
workers is disgusting and it's all to
drive wages down and increase profits
for the shareholders slash owners
now on to my idiotic rules
uh left lane hogs would lose their right
to drive
if you can't do something as simple as
being the proper lane at the right
[ __ ] time then you can't drive
the can i speak to your manager haircut
would be outlawed
well then how do you know one of those
people is coming in
um
anyway uh
i love how they socially distant during
the after the [ __ ]
game interview and then the second it's
over they like hug the reporter
um the game like uh let's see you know
the haircut what haircut i'm talking
about the short in the back longer in
the front typical karen haircut any
scammers will be put to get death anyone
who abuses an animal a child or an
elderly would suffer the exact same
abuse unless it merits death like child
rape
yeah you should go to [ __ ] right to
the goddamn
gas chamber for that then nearing the
end of my life i'd give the country back
to the natives condolences for the the
loss of your friend
bob and dog cleo uh
love you bill take care well there's
somebody in their heart
he's doing everything for somebody else
that's what would make him suspicious
to everybody in power
wait this guy wants to do things for
other people
um
oh phil sims got the bed head big time
this week um all right if i were a
dictator
all right here we go if i were a
uh hey billy big bucks
yeah sorry not the best nickname i know
uh i got thinking what would be what
would a country be like if i were a
dictator here are some rules i'd set off
the top of my head one
get rid of the national banks
only regional ones allowed the big banks
did some shady stuff back in 2008 ruined
people's lives and tanked the economy
imagine the stuff we don't know they did
companies or a single person won't be
able to skirt around it by owning
multiple regional banks too big to fail
would be a thing of the past
yeah you got a lot of people you're
gonna have to whack right there buddy
um in a five-year plan phase out all
plastic materials unless they are
medically necessary for equipment in
hospitals or doctor's offices this is a
huge huge reason why the pollution
problem is so bad also bring back the
concept of repairing appliances yes in
your home rather than buying brand new
ones when there's one minor thing wrong
with it
another huge culprit of the population
problem yeah yeah
it's cheaper to buy a new one
uh get the government to regulate
airlines and to bring back the railroad
system
i remember a few years back someone sent
in an email to you explaining while the
quality of the airline experience had
deteriorated and it's the cause
and it's because the government
deregulated the airlines i think in the
mid to late 70s got the hiccups now
sorry and some as someone who's been
packed in the pl in a plane and felt
like a sardine it would be great if i
had a flying experience like i've read
about in the pan am days well you still
had to be up front
you still had to be up front
yeah pan am first class to new york
you'd land and you'd get off the plane
get on a helicopter and they would land
on top of the pan am building
which is now the uh
jesus christ i've been out of new york
that long i forget what it's called
it was used it was the one right at the
end of uh
was it park avenue
madison avenue what the [ __ ] is it
called
i don't know yeah they landed there one
day somebody [ __ ] rolled the
helicopter and went off the side and
people died
but up until then they flew you from jfk
to the top of the pan am building
you got out and went into a [ __ ] ron
burgundy bar
you know and had drinks and there was a
car downstairs waiting
for you to drive you to your hotel after
you had a couple of pops
and talk to some lovely ladies amazing
can you imagine the [ __ ] call girls
hanging out at that place
you know
and all you had to worry about was
gonorrhea and they had [ __ ]
penicillin i mean it was it was over
it was over then along came herpes um
all right
herpes in a helicopter [ __ ] accident
that was the end of that all right now i
bring back the railroad then i bring
back the uh okay we truly be a special
occasion and get rid of the riffraff you
see these days now i bring the railroads
back
as a genuine means of transportation as
an alternative to flying and it would
lower air pollution think of how many
unnecessary cars around the road and it
would create jobs here's something i
don't understand is all the unnecessary
traveling
i don't understand with all this zoom
technology we all got business done
during the pandemic why are there so
many people going to the [ __ ] airport
hang on a second sorry
there's too many people
being taken away from their families and
having to fly when they don't need to
when they could easily just [ __ ] get
on a goddamn
zoom call but i just don't think the
[ __ ]
like it they want you there they want
you to get on a plane and go there so
they can sit there and look at you and
try to read it it's too much freedom
i mean how do we know they're even
wearing pants you know they probably
have a nice tasty snack right next to
their computer they're probably having
fun
um if you pronounce the candy reese's
pieces as racy's pcs
in my presence
it will be mandatory one month jail
sentence why to keep people on their
toes i don't want them getting too
comfortable
you can celebrate christmas and have
donations out in december and only in
december none of this selling christmas
stuff in november give thanksgiving room
to breathe and no christmas lights
still up
and on in february thousand dollar fine
every day there
uh they are up starting on january 1st
uh
anyway these are some of the rules off
the top of my head thanks for an awesome
podcast and go [ __ ] yourself i love
those rules
we got some dictators with the heart of
gold here
on this goddamn podcast um listening to
this podcast i should say
trying to think if i have one
um i think i ran out of mine's just all
petty [ __ ]
the big thing though is i really want
some i want somebody really cerebral and
i want you to tell me
how you could be a dictator for the
people keep the rich people in the
military at bay
and you can somehow stay in power
that is your mission should you choose
to accept it all right
okay i'm gonna watch the rest of this
game
and i'm gonna take a little nyquil and
sleep this [ __ ] off and uh
i think i'll be all right and i'll be
back in [ __ ] action
tomorrow um all right that is it that is
the podcast everybody congratulations
to the nfl great weekend of football
it was as exciting as the weekend before
was not congratulations to your san
francisco 49ers to your los angeles rams
to your cincinnati bengals and the
winner of the bill's kansas city um
i got to admit i think
if uh i think the rams might do it i
think they have the [ __ ] defense they
got the coach
and they got a nice qb there with
stafford i don't know
that defense i don't see anybody else
who's got a defense like what they got
and defense i still believe wins
championships but then again i also
think you should kick a field goal
in the first half i don't know
i'm [ __ ] nuts like that all right
that's it okay
second house beginning
go [ __ ] yourselves and i'll see you in a
couple of days